Other languages are statically typed. And this is one of the biggest differences
between programming languages. Here's an example of what some code statically
typed language like Java or C might look like. First, before we use a new name,
say the name x, we have to declare it. And what this type declaration means is
the name x that we're introducing here will only refer to values of type int.
So, we could assign the value 3 to x, 3 is an int. What we couldn't do is assign
the string hello undacious one to x. This is going to be a type error and it's a
type error at compile time. That means we get this error before we even run the
program. As an another example, if we wanted to find a function in a language
like Java or C, where we have to say what type it has. So, this is the return
type. And we have to give the type of each parameter. If we have code somewhere
else that calls the procedure with an object that is not in it. We're going to
get an error at compile time.